à la flamme de la paix de l'amour de la
transcendance orbitale équatoriale du
prince est de la vinaigrette de l'eau et
de l'oignon saluer votre dieu en vous
prosternant devant le bac à légumes
le monde d un union entre en ruine is
our world our où nous sommes à tes
genoux vous prosternez vous de l'autre
côté les oignons sont là mais les
dragons du jeune disciple de lui montrer
votre face au partant mais pardon par
tout le monde et un de nyon chantant à
l'unisson m guru nous sommes dit gilou
resté agenouillé un repas vous êtes
servi qu'au bout en bout
m je ne vois pas les trois grains de riz
complet a bit more lie les assiettes
sont vides mais tu n'as pas besoin de
visualiser est à nourriture pour te
nourrir laich et appréhende-t-on et
cruel qui est ce bel objet qui sert à te
nourrir et tu ne le connaissais pas
jusqu alors tu apprendras à le connaître
c'est beau comme on s'aime on croise et
promet des trois principaux os pour
sammy bossut aussi bien m or m cheveux
or propre nom n'abuse pas tu te ferait
du mal maintenant que tu t'es bien
nourrie vance à ceux qui ont faim et
ceux qui souffraient tu voudrais
s'ouvrir toi aussi au millimètre ne
marteau le marco le marteau
merci mr alors merci m
non ne puisse pas de freddie mac
maintenant ton corps est apaisée et plus
encore dans ton esprit de mauvaises
pensées et de vilaine idée avoue t faute
oui m je m'accuse du péché de
gourmandise s'est tenue en cachette je
me suis relevé je suis allée sucer un
oignon bowen m je m'accuse de péché de
gourmandise
je me souviens avoir bu un verre d'eau
entier dans la seule journée d'hier
m j'ai connu plus court dans dix ans
plus des trois grains de riz complet
offert par l'état barad j'en ai su c'est
un quatrième pour vivre et assurer la
sexualité de groupe de ce soir je vous
pose une question préliminaire
lequel d'entre vous a réussi à accomplir
l'acte d'h hypostase extasié cette nuit
nous ne m ou 2 mai lequel de vous peut
recommencer la même opération cette nuit
aussi celle qui viendra devant votre
gourou à côté avec et par la jeune femme
elle non pas moi j'en peux plus mettre
non j'en veux plus oui
avant d'aller sur vos couches aide avant
d'aller travailler
avez vous pensé au canoë colis de vos
familles
oui mais je ne nomme tout jeune garde de
rien tu es tout et je ne suis rien
je te donne tout jeune gars de rien tu
es tour et je ne suis rien n'est plus
rien m n'a plus rien at m
combien tu fais de clients cette nuit
125 c'est bien ton cas n'est pas
désespérée qui peut aller prendre et
mangé un oignon pour te rassasié merci m
avant d'aller aux ateliers d'aller
prêcher la bonne parole en allant
répandre la vérité allons faire de la
musique
m j'ai brisé ma tâche est tout le jeu de
son cas c'est très bien vous serez punis
en ne mangeant pas de nourriture ni de
boissons pendant trois jours et trois
nuits vous mettiez m merci aller au bout
d un oignon
bonjour merci bonjour petit matin comme
vous avez déjà les rouleaux petit matin
toute la gamme de toile est axé là
devant ces missiles parfumée à quoi le
mot rojas ma p'tite madame et le vert à
la menthe petit monde est plat à la
neige me dit madame et j'ai ainsi
tromper dit madame est bien à l'as union
petite madame et les marrons aux marrons
au petit madame effet permis
et là bas qu'il est mieux écouter
choisissez petite madame soit 10 et
faites votre choix
c'est par ici lequel le conseiller vous
je vous conseille de nous marron leurs
dernières nouveautés touché le jura oui
oui elle a chanté bien non retouchées
mieux je touche êtes vous chantez pas
non il est lavable petit matin mais
regardez tous ces papiers toilettes
ordinaire on les prend on s'en sert et
on les jette alors que celui-ci loupé un
coup d'épongé
à trois les taxes cela va bien notre
groupe vous faire toute une vie eh bien
vous mettrez dit houle au home adama
gros besoins salaires valable à tous que
je résilie mon abonnement à l'humain
ça les filles a dit dans les films dans
les points de boîtes de tout ce que
j'aimais alors mais vous rigolez s'est
pas vu comment je suis tanné mois il
faut des bus vers à ce super absorbants
bugarach moubarak super dit l'asn versé
en vain
germaine donne moi un boudoir pour
tremper dans mon vin chéri est-ce que tu
mets mais qu'est ce qui attend je ne te
plaît plus on était charmante et très
mignonne mais tu refoule du boulot ça
faisait 9e matin j'arrive pour bien
nettoyer avant lundi il n'est pas
toujours impeccable c'est une fille que
les pins récurent accès spécial dentier
grâce à récurage spécial dentier un
petit nuage point-ci récurent axe avant
le voit ci après grâce à l'accord inclut
entier mordez la vie à pleines dents
germaine il reste du pain pour sow ses
bidasses et mademoiselle j'aime pas les
grossiers chapeau au chapeau rouge rue
paul bert et définitif
je me rase amis amoureuse
malheureusement raté à cause des
problèmes pellicule et ils devraient
plutôt employer pellicule ait un droit
plus tard le même jeune homme dans la
même boîte de nuit alors coupé on lance
grossier et au chapeau bas le japon est
ta plus merci mélégué lac
geremek da le ramasse-miettes quoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle pût soulèvera ces
portables
oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai je
transpire mais la femme moderne à
l'heure actuelle a le droit de
transpirer autant que l'homme
puisqu'elle travaille alors faites comme
moi utiliser pinsac aux eaux au cepac
nabeul en on s'appuie toujours otages
au net sans plus rien oui non plus merci
10dans germaine le pain tu l'a ramené
sous ton bras
un petit creux une petite faim à toute
heure du jour et de la nuit demandé
saucisson [ __ ] axe à sec ou allied
sont si son cachot nax en août ont
montré du saucisson alors jean sur
fromage
alors quand la télé je vais leur écrire
moi
au sauna on verra ce qu'on voudra sans
doute en a aussi bien fait d'engager
plus tendue laurent tu feras tu m'as
soirée long ça me tire la dernière riche
des témoins
tiens vous avez vos chaussons oui je
transpire des pieds alors en chaussant
je suis plus à mon aise
marie-catherine ma chérie nous n'aurions
pas dû virent le jour d'ouverture du
salon de l'agriculture
ils sont venus ils sont tous là les
croyants bonjour mesdames
même le haut très bonne surprise
je ne pensais pas que nous allions
rencontrer des dames avant d'aller nous
débarbouiller apolline dioum dan ils ont
laissé leur tracteur alors dit ne vous
ont plu alors merci maintenant pardon
mesdames et ce que nous devons faire la
queue après derrière vous afin de
l'ouvrir une baignoire pour nous
débrouiller au préalable a coûté votre
robot je regrette c'est vous madame la
préposée au dic est baignoire
oui c'est moi nous aurions voulu louer
une baignoire pour deux personnes
pendant une heure afin de nous
débrouiller au préalable bah écoutez je
nous faire couler un petit bain moussant
fille si vous voulez que vos potes le
dos se sent pas très bon accueil pour
les nouveaux venus au club
apolline sont ce des hommes ou des
animaux avant les regarder dans l'autre
cas ils sont monstrueuses et une horreur
insoutenable au bord de l'asphyxié
aurions nous ouvrir une fenêtre en
raison de la chaleur mais ma cuillère si
le soleil bouche lgbt store dans une
minute parce que c'est pas normal mais
reçues adam il nous fait un peu chaud
c'est combien massage madame 1,50 point
complet aux pour moi vous frais induits
complet bien que le port pour 75 fond et
pour moi rien que le haut pour la même
somme
nous pourrions peut-être vous offrir de
bonnes consommation bien fraîche en
raison de la chaleur madame anne pauline
jeunes y résistent plus amusant nous
marie galerie la cantine on nous d'enppi
à thé à la menthe la via deux thés à la
menthe avec à sa tête dans un corps pur
ou bien frais
et un rosé sec ballon bien frappé par
micha merci j'ai déjeuné avant de venir
se montrant manches et j'ai des renvois
mois
n'aurait pas dû prendre autant de gras
doubles à midi surtout avec la bière
marie-catherine mais très chaud en cette
chaleur insoutenable et bienfaisante
oui non peut-être pas encore à s'échouer
j'ai crevé moi mais j'espère 10 pour
détendre et vous allez attraper du mal
oui vous n'êtes pas très bien couvert
pour aller dans un bain glacé il me
semble et 4,40 et la l'orangerie
pardon je ne vois pas les pichets où
sont dont les consommations alcoolisées
madame vous ne vous êtes pas une
brasserie si vous êtes nationale mais
nous payons tout de même une certaine
somme coquette et rondelette
oui et nous n'aimons pas la tisanerie
qu'ont coûté les rustica complet à
massage complet de prix léo qui le bar
alors moi c'est l'eau pour me raffermir
un peu les ceux qui ont tendance à
s'accélérer
ah nan moi ce serait pour me raffermir
les fesses et ont tendance à se ramollir
au contact du siège de mon tracteur et
veut ainsi défait au pas lent chez vous
la merci madame bien madame faites dans
comme on vous dit vous voulez fait mal
aussi mais pas plus je ne suis pas plus
peuplés pas me taper dans le monde nous
payons une bonne semaine
il sort chez bhl et or en ce moment fini
c'est insoutenable
laurent je le range a dit ferri
moi
bon cela mesdames bonsoir mes
demoiselles et bonsoir messieurs en tant
qu ancien mannequin j'ai le plaisir de
vous présenter ce soir la grande
collection été hiver dans le cadre
grandiose du salon de l'agriculture est
apportée et vous commencez jacky qui
nous présente un blouson sport de chez
cacharel et maintenant le chez christian
d'or deux combinaisons télescope
présenté par daniel et gérard
2g clan pas une petite tenue
décontractée légère pour une démarche
légères et décontractées
donc on devrait plus vos poches de
mouchoirs salles à partir de maintenant
utiliser les pulls jetables que vous
propose crash art l oif maintenant
maintenant pour les hommes les vrais
c'est du béton vous propose une tenue
par a vraiment viril
n'oublions pas les femmes de ménage qui
veulent être ainsi des femmes du monde
appréciez les chapes doute d'où les
chars qui joint l'utile à l'agréable
présenté par jean huguin pantalon
vraiment très élastique et de chez
moulinex
surprenez votre partenaire en portant le
slip en acier trempé que vous propose
fourrage
c'est bien mais
vous êtes nerveux vous voulez arrêter de
fumer
faites comme gérard porter une cravate
et réglisse
voici sans heurt des prêts un ravissant
fire de chez crash harel présenté par
barbara barbara c'est mal à y avait par
an dans la salle de chez skippy marque
australienne
voici une semaine la camp gourou nous
continuerons avec un pull en poil de
chameau de chez offrons chamelle le même
modèle d'ailleurs en pitbull
vous monsieur une nouveauté
révolutionnaire la braguette beat bit
qui vous prévient quand elle est ouverte
de chez big baby foot chez epic au ray
ban et lunettes qui permettent de voir
les autres nus vous êtes restaurateur
n'hésitez pas offrez la tenue et j
tiennent à votre garçon de café là
surprenez vos amis changé de visage en
portant la peyrie rotative bolus
chaussures font du bruit utiliser les
chaussures
bonjour monsieur bonjour
monsieur monsieur fromage
bonjour aujourd'hui
bonjour
voilà je voudrais connaître en à venir
il paraît que c'est possible vous lisez
m'a-t-on dit dans les lignes de la main
bien sûr 50 francs s'il vous plaît bien
sûr attendus voici merci pas de boulot
maboulou 50 francs pour mon book
voici vous êtes salarié
oui oui vous risquez de perdre votre
emploi prochainement c'est pas vrai vous
en êtes sûr
ah on n'est jamais sûr pour être sûr il
faudrait consulter la boule mais c'est
plus cher
ah bon c'est combien à bressan franc de
100 francs pour être sur écoute et je
vais voir tenait alors pour la poule a
joué à vous avez retrouvé votre travail
à vous partez souvent en voyage
vous conduisez une automobile exact je
la vois qui roulait qui s'écrase contre
un mur
vous risquez de perdre la vie vous est
cher
on n'est jamais sûr pour être sûr je
dois consulter les cartes mais c'est
plus cher
avancez sait combien les 4 500 en france
500 francs attendez que les messieurs
500 francs pour les cartes à leur
sang-froid bolloc'h maboulou 500 francs
pour mon goût
alors vous avez la vie sauve ah ah mais
votre femme est malade
elle est sérieusement malade elle risque
elle aussi de mourir dans un avenir très
proche
mais je n'en suis pas sûr pour en être
sûr je devrais interroger les astres à
ses mille francs
elles risquent de mourir on va mettre
sur j'interroge les bases pour mille
francs non mais c'est tout ce que je
voulais savoir matin de ma déjà coûté
assez cher au revoir monsieur bonjour
monsieur monsieur plus bas très bien
j'aurais voulu s'il vous plaît monsieur
que vous me disiez tout ce qui va se
passer en 1984 s'il vous plaît dans
toute l'année oui oui toute l'année
conjoncture mondiale pour moi même et
écouter alors là je peux pas vous
prendre aujourd'hui avant je suis
débordé de home au printemps même pour
cet été tout et je ne vois qu'une classe
on aime voir le 22 décembre
84 14 heures 14 heures ni très bon très
bien il a vous pourrez voir tout ce qui
se passe en 95 voilà je vous dirai tout
ce qui s'est passé dans la neige vous
fera un résumé
merci monsieur plumage à leur merci
beaucoup
aujourd'hui je suis à lui non bonjour
monsieur je voulais savoir ce qui va se
passer dans ma vie dans un avenir assez
proche très proche wheels et ses proches
mais le plus proche possible dans un
avenir mais ultra proches
oui vous allez me donner 500 francs et
vous allez partir ah bon merci je vous
dois combien 500 france
oui données mais aussi bien au revoir
monsieur merci beaucoup
l'expérience
la cure de la fois c'est la toile
hommage l'a1 c'est là le match tu m'as
produit on admire ya un an la nature la
bombasse au château farrebique tétouan
tanger en fonction sur la tête haute
enchère de loi parce que là tu m'as
trahi de montclos ça allait je suis
chômeur la femme ça allez allez allez
mort à bagnolet les casser partez pas
plus âgés que moi je suis curieux de
comprendre ce qui est arrivé à tous à se
tarir oui vous allez me casser la gueule
cette maj allons pousser chez je vous
avoue j'ai eu un doute au départ vous
excusez moi mais c'est complètement
désolé de vous déranger je ne vais pas
rester très longtemps
mais voilà ce qui m'amène c'est que je
suis votre voisine
vous voyez la fenêtre la barre enfin si
vous alors voilà c'est que tu as tout
petit problème parce que quand je prends
ma douche
elle veille à une longue vue qui se
pointent vers chez moi et puis arrêtez
moi si je me trompe heures et témoin
tout de suite mais j'ai bien
l'impression que ça vienne chez vous
cette nuit là alors il faudrait
peut-être arrêter parce que tout ça le
voisinage ça risque jazz et vous avez vu
ma carte de visite avait atteint 10
messieurs fromage voyant et oui voyons
c'est mon métier
je dois vous regardez si je vous observe
c'est pas par plaisir à bombay c'est mon
métier madame je vous dois quelque chose
ailleurs non c'est pas la peine
continuer de prendre des douches trois
fois par jour sur monsieur dos n'a pas
bonjour monsieur je vois là je vais vous
voir parce que je voudrais savoir quand
est-ce que je vais avoir ma première
expérience sexuelle
je vais consulter ma boule
quel âge avez-vous 35 ans je ne vois
rien dans un avenir proche
ah bon vous riez pas il n'y a pas une
femme jolie n'ont ni femme n'est autre
chose
même pas une petite femme mêmes proies
pour le non non non j'ai déjà bien
regarder ya pas de femme revient non n'y
a pas de bombe et excusez moi je vais me
débrouiller tout seul est-ce qu'il vous
prend vous êtes voyage je voyais en
voyons oui autant pour moi d'accord
bonjour monsieur monsieur go alors voilà
monsieur je voudrais savoir mon avenir
s'il vous plaît je vous écoute
alors je vois que vous avez une santé de
fer
vous n'êtes jamais malade a dit le
groupe depuis trois semaines je m'en
débarrasse pas vous gagnerez beaucoup
d'argent plus tard oui s'il augmente le
smig où il ya des chances je vois que
vous allez être heureuse avec un homme
dans le prénom commence par un gps
entonné un il s'appelle gaston était
parti à trois semaines bien à et enfin
vous allez vivre centenaire madame oui à
bergen argh
harlow
heureusement qu'elle est morte sinon ma
réputation était fait
oui il était une fois qu'en tant city un
pasteur un pic mais bien le whisky ayew
moi et mes quatre filles on domine la
ville
j'ai pendu leur mère pour être plus
tranquille
non
m
ghost vous à tout cela on peut y aller
ok
dabadie
11ème la terreur puisque
jama
mais qui
ok de ce soir est comme moi je suis
calamity mcdonald's et je triche au
casino spar la dalle
à toute l'étape jours mais vite dans
tous les tripes on m'appelle n'y fait
moi je suis là grand p dit mado nage des
valises les banques en descente de mange
pas
le manque des dollars mais nous laisse
tomac dans toute la région on m'appelle
big man
ok le king moi je suis là tu aimais les
filles madonna du mappy seulement d'un
corset par balles au saloon spaety
surtout les sauf les cowboys m'appelle
me super coq jacques mayoux ses fans
cambrai mois travaillés john tu coules
tiers foule
moi je suis la gâchette défi mcdonald's
jeudi pour un rien attention les balles
pour un seul dollar
nous allons gens avec des shérifs du
point il m'appelle mitschek
oh
on est là croit rêver déjà tu
or die ans
passionné des filles ont dérapé
vers le pasteur est encore pire
à
non
il était une fois quand city un pasteur
un piqué mais bien le whisky moi et mes
quatre filles on domine la ville jets
pendu leur mère pour être plus
tranquille
la nana
d'être le fils est fini on va traîner
dans les bars je vais vous présenter
quatre garçons ils vous seront utiles ce
les frères dalton
on l'a
bonjour bonjour les petits une nouvelle
histoire dans son hôtel particulier de
neuilly la reine s'entretient
secrètement avec son miroir miroir we
hear what
je suis toujours la plus belle femme du
monde
c'était un bon t'es pas mal enfin deux
camps même sur wii commence à gagner ses
principales amis à blanche neige sur les
vaches posions à pois l'abbé ouais j'y
coup elle se rend aussitôt au bois labbé
au fond de la forêt entre 2000n grue
d'un vilain est très méchant chantiers
de construction nos sept joyeux petit
compagnon reviennent d'une dure journée
de labeur aller à l'eau
ils étaient 7
ils étaient neuf c'est à les sept nains
tahar et bojan
bara à faire un petit lamboley rigueur
alors les filles on baigne militants les
ventes d'or 3 y est moitié moins pis là
je voudrais voir la dame blanche mais au
coeur de la banane j'ai peur d'un retour
et swing avoir dit bo
ils sont sept
ils font les trois huit
bamako à la maison au quand ils arrivent
au logis il se met à table rosé c'est
encore moi qui sert la soupe
ouais merci richard
merci corbigeois bien s'y faire c'est
bien monté merci papa
elle est bonne
auj vous croyez qu'elle va venir
soudain on entend frapper ya 17 qui peut
venir vont s instaure bas c'est être
blanche neige devrait créer frais qu'ils
ont planché tuer blanche neige comme
cible en semaine bonjour bonjour madame
blanche dans la dope
ouais alors servir à toi
alalalala
blanche neige blanche neige blanche
neige c'est pas tout ça tranquillement
on se couche et comme je suis content
d'être protégé par ses sept petits
compagnons je vais dormir tranquille
mademoiselle blanche mèche c'est moi
c'est bis la novice à ma part j'ai tout
de suite non mais des fois on recherche
blanche neige
j'ai des problèmes avec ma banane
voulait pas m'aider
hippie bon présentons pour le transport
après les récents au petit matin quand
elle se réveille alors que les oiseaux
chanter que les renoncules sorte gretel
interdit hier la petite blanche neige
pendant que les nains sont au travail
ça donne au taf du ménage à tiaret 1,6 à
ces avis cela
tout d'un coup à la porte
l'oeil aux aguets la sorcière vilaines
et méchantes réparé un machiavélique
super fut l'un tient on a frappé 4
octobre la saône et ça lui va et est
nouvelle dans boîte super-héros la
baraque cette maquereau au t2 gens âgés
face à peine comme owen ne passe vite
zappé un dieu je lis des bananes
justement j'ai perdu la vierge
chargement mais si j com merci je ne me
sens pas bien je crois que je vais me
rendormir
la marche i hear what we hear what went
wrong
est-ce que je suis toujours la plus
belle femme du monde est appliquée les
acheter une pomme dans le fond marin
juste parce qu'il ya un cap suédoise qui
gagnent des parts ya pas mal avec rome
agence fides de thoiry aux jets une
raison d'arrivée le premier
l'anc neige fait - sévissent là haut
lm aux gitans d'arrivée le second mais
qu'est ce qui se passe
blanche-neige m un des hommes mais non
est ce qu'elle est mort pendant les
heures passent à célébrer leur part je
lui fais
bhutta commandes voici le jeune et beau
prince charmant blanche neige
je peine à l'éloge du caire où il se
livre beige
habib habibou ses copies en version
raffinée
bien sûr bien sûr beaucoup ta faim gens
sur bien sûr et c'est à l'église jeu va
prendre fin notre belle et tendre
histoire une classe sacem
ah ah
souvenez vous voulez pas tu prend
combien est litres
un litre c'est du baratin de la
gourmandise non là je vous assure je
vous fais pas le boniment même un petit
peu non un litre c'est la quantité
réglementaire maintenant s'il vous plaît
je vous en supplie des mois je vous
assure on a besoin de vous les gars ya
tellement peu de gens qui passent ici
j'ai pas arrivé à faire mon quota moi
aujourd'hui je préfère quand vous me
parlez plus gentiment pas ce que je vais
vous expliquer une chose pour moi c'est
la première fois ci vous dire moi aussi
c'est la première fois ça vous effraie
pas j'espère au contraire je trouve ça
plutôt sympathique
c'est vrai la première fois les jo sont
souvent nerveux contracté pour ce que ça
fait mal et il tourner de l'oeil tombe
dans les formes vous inquiétez pas s'il
y en a un des deux qui tombe dans les
pommes ce sera vous peut-être de bonheur
à main dessus et je vous rassure tout de
suite il n'y a personne qui va tomber
dans les pommes
marc dieu vous allez vous décontracter
vous allonger et quand vous êtes prêts
moi j'y vais je me décontracte quand
vous êtes prêt de givet quand vous êtes
prêt gilbert bien avant bien sûr une
chose le garrot
alors parce que vous strangulation on
est obligé ces mêmes conseillers sinon
risque d accident pour nous oui il faut
il faut que ça gonfle pourquoi vous
faites ça mais pourrait pour aider des
millions de gens vous vous pouvez pas
imaginer celui-ci ne nous assure
quelques minutes ensemble ici vies
humaines de sauver oui bon n'exagérons
rien s'il suffisait d'aller voir une
dame pour publier de problème et puis
quand on y va vous êtes d'accord
bon d'accord on y va là bas c'est dans
le camion
en fait ça dans un camion oui mais enfin
dans la remorque 1
j'ai pas faire votre elle est venue à
sur le trottoir allez allez je vous
rejoins or non mais franchement on va
falloir finir faire les [ __ ] pourra
obtenir le globule frêche